and we are live the last word with lord
cognito ibontis and ty guy travis fresh
on that witch queen eve i would say
we're close we're close but let's start
with you man what's going on with you
bro
first
uh i have been i've like checked
basically every box for which queen prep
like 186 bounties
just kind of everything done last thing
i need to do is just kind of tidy up a
couple things and i just want to like
set it down over the weekend and not
think about destiny before tuesday which
is going to be absolutely crazy so
travis what about you you got another
game that you can throw under all the
bus tires
i do not i do not thankfully i hopefully
that's the worst review i have to write
this year but uh yeah as you guys know
i've been on a content tirade at ign
just doing i think i did like six
reviews and a bunch of previews and
working on wikis and i'm basically all
wrapped up with all of my ign work until
uh the witch queen so now it's all just
prep and then i'm doing that review man
i'm gonna be on destiny for like 11 days
straight or however long it takes for me
to get the raid done and then uh write
it up so it's gonna be a sprint and i'm
so excited for it guys i'm very i'm
actually hyped for the first time in a
long time for a destination because
usually i'm like so close to it i can't
really be hyped like beyond light just
like i felt like i knew what that dlc
was before it even came out and i was
right
but i feel like witch queen i kind of
don't know
i feel like i know less
nice what about you what do you got what
have you been doing ready man i've been
in prep bowl just been kind of raiding a
little bit just getting spoils up trying
to knock out terrible the last thing
that i need to get done but um bounties
prepped iron banner will get done i am
ready man it's that time this is the
season you know what did we do now so
but we we've been procrastinating i know
we got some special royalty that we need
to introduce east so bring them in all
right so full intro here we go
what up you nerds welcome to the last
word episode number 185
season of loss tripped its way over the
finish line but which queen the hype
train is truly running at full speed
many hours of sleep will be lost server
q numbers will see new highs and
blueberries will be as clueless as ever
but it's safe to say many of us are
excited and we couldn't have asked for a
better guest on this near eve of this
epic launch this band has been breaking
down shooter mechanics since you've been
in diapers and the game of choice that
started his love of shooters none other
than halo halo holds a special place in
this man's heart not only because this
started his youtube career please go
watch that first video
but he also met his wife because of it
so to say it is life-changing is
actually not an overstatement the real
reason many of you know our guest though
is likely because of his ability to just
discuss any topic with all players from
cone angle enthusiasts to johnny day job
two thumbs he's sure to have you rolling
on the floor laughing from the memes
jokes and one-liners in each of his
videos
it takes true talent to be able to talk
about the exact effective range of
shotguns as measured by darcy in the way
that makes you feel both informed and
entertained yet confused and sad inside
he is a true unicorn in this community
and can truly shift the destiny meta
both in game and in content creation
with just one video
so let's welcome our resident destiny
memeologist a man who understands how
your vault could be 525 out of 500 after
a vault cleaning
owner of a phb i said phb that's pretty
huge barrel
spends an hour
to put together a 60-second tentacle
face just to nail that one bit will
punish himself for 50 games in a row
unless he dies to shatter dive of course
and embraces all things warlock floating
his way to the finish line he is a man
who sits evenly on both butt cheeks
because his ridge wallet has no bulge he
has trimmed lord jack's junk and lived
to tell the tale
and he even knows always that there is
plenty of money in the banana stand has
some fine knife skills in the kitchen
knows its waffles over pancakes and
knows when frying to always lay away
host of the firing range podcast for all
things crucible science and i have no
doubt we'll own that elusive gold play
button on youtube so go subscribe to his
channel if somehow you aren't already
your jabronis
the official hype train conductor who is
sitting in front of his white board of
sound foam and in his chair that needs
to be replaced with his rage shadow
legends money the one the only fallout
plays man how are you doing
wow i gotta tell you boys i've been on a
lot of
podcasts in my day
y'all did your homework
uh that was probably the best intro i've
ever gotten ever
so much deeper than i thought she would
have gone um it's because of that wow
that's just wild uh well thank you thank
you very much for having me on the show
thrilled to be here
absolutely
yeah i've been a long time coming long
time coming for sure i'm coming brother
cherry montes i think we have the same
chair
oh you and him yeah that looks very it
looks very similar very simple maybe
yeah over there show me that chair
yeah i'm off the uh i'm off the gaming
chair
uh train i'm on the office chair now
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah ergonomics all the way
was making me my back was getting a
little stiff i know it's like the oldest
thing i could say oh my back was mad
stuff but like i don't know just
in time i've heard from many people you
got to go for the office chair so i went
for the office chair i'm liking it no
doubt
we got the crucible scientists in the
campfire today so it's good i was gonna
ask you this um
obviously the name right sure when i
came across your your content this was
like d1 early and i had a lot of
bethesda guys like mad at you they were
like how dare he have that name
and he's a destiny so can you just
explain to the to those people you know
how you stuck with it sure yeah it's
funny if people
hear the word fallout and it's like you
know people out there you know that the
word fallout is also like it's just a
word right it doesn't only have to be
tied to the game franchise these words
can have multiple meanings it's a fun
fact something you should know um but
yeah way back
in the day when i was trying to come up
with a new gamertag or whatever
pre-youtube
days i was just thinking of all my
favorite you mentioned in the intro love
halo yes i used to be really into like
mlg tournament level halo
and like all my favorite
pro players all had like short
badass one-word names right it was like
ogre
walshy neighbor
pistola
toxic they all had cool like one word
names and i was like i need like a cool
one-word name
i was just saying
remember back in the day when you had
like
like a cd tower
of all the all the games that you had or
whatever it's like old school gamer [ __ ]
like oh yeah looking around for like
inspiration you got the cd tower back
there or whatever i'm like oh fallout
like
this is before fallout 3. so back then
before fallout 3 it was kind of like it
was a little different
uh not as not as popular and it was like
oh those were cool memories those were
like i used to play the game with my
buddy back in the day good gaming
memories it's a short cool
one-word name i was like bam i'm gonna
be fallout and that was like my halo
gamer tag and then when i wanted to make
a youtube channel i was like well what
do i make it and that was back
when all the rage was like the let's
plays were all really popular
so everyone's like oh you like the
really common to see youtube channel
names like oh so and so plays i was like
fall out perfect
if i could if i could go back in time
and take a different youtuber
if i could find a way
it's fine now but it was just really
annoying for a while when people can be
like ooh what do you what is your name
that
was like forget it already it's too long
to explain
don't worry about it
open it up for the uh fellas because we
know we got times limited so we want to
get
questions in trav
yeah my question is
um with the witch queen
right around the corner and us all
thinking about we know whether it's
gonna
revolutionize the world of destiny or
kind of be more the same i think is a
lot of what the people who who play a
lot of destiny are thinking
i was wondering
and this is coming from somebody who's
who has to review it
what
what do you think could
make destiny uh could make the witch
queen
a huge success like what specifically do
you have to do to make you just just get
above the threshold of like
you know the sevens that i you know i
gave them to
shadow keep and to be on light and i
stand by those right like what what is
that sure get past that threshold into
greatness and what are some things it
could do that you think would uh kind of
confine it to
mediocrity or or even make it like a
failure like oh wow that's a really good
question um
i
i mean
part of the thing is that everybody's
you know individual review of which
queen is going to be slightly different
right it's like maybe if you're huge in
a gambit you would you might rate witch
queen much higher because you know they
just put out their their little bullet
plan to to kind of reinvigorate gambit
but um but for me
uh if they had like a killer raid
i think the weapon crafting system is
going to be huge because that's
something we haven't really ever had in
destiny before we had
weapon reforging y'all remember back in
d1 when they oh yeah yeah a little
weaponry forging there which was great
for what it was
but now they're going really in depth
with being able to re-craft reforged
weapons i think if they really nail that
then that would be a huge
huge leg up in my book because i think
people are
we all love the thrill of getting a god
roll but nobody wants to like
go through the like when there's a
really cool gambit weapon which is rare
but you know you have like i don't know
bottom dollar hand cannon or something
that's like you have to get lucky 65 000
options later
yeah good god like you have to play 20
games a gambit to even get the freaking
thing to drop and then when it does drop
it's got 12 unique perks in column three
for it what are the mathematical odds
that you're gonna get a role that you're
kind of maybe happy with uh so crushing
the weapon and crafting system would be
huge uh i don't know about y'all but
i've heard a lot of i think i'm going to
make a free to play account to
maybe better understand
the new light experience
experience it's like really
bad right now they just don't explain a
lot so i think if bungie does more
to help the new players the numbers will
be better
which i think will make for a healthier
game experience overall
and uh and yeah i think those are some
steps in the right direction and what
would they do to make it kind of fall
flat
oh gosh i don't know if we just get more
of the same i mean i know we all love
the game but like
shake it up i think the weapon crafting
is a really good
a really good shake-up i think void 3.0
is a good shake-up um
but yeah if they just
if those kind of fall flat then i'd be a
little disappointed okay so to succeed
you got
raid it's gotta have a great raid great
radio weapon crafting yep and uh
there was a third one better experience
yeah that's huge yeah
yeah and then just to fail basically
just to not hit on those things
basically you pretty much
yeah yeah got it okay
no doubt eat
ah i got one i got one more i want to
sneak it oh get it go yeah you go this
will kind of take us mine will take us a
little into
the trailer talk real quick so you go so
mr fallout i gotta ask you like we know
we got those loadouts we're all kind of
scheming the meta is gonna change
there's a lot of crafting's gonna come
in a lot of new weapons are coming so we
don't know everything yet but my
question for you is like come raid time
okay what tried and true what peanut
butter and jelly might you crutch on
from a loadout standpoint
just in case the new stuff ain't up to
snuff and you need whether it be dps or
situational stuff i know it's a broad
question no that's fine i think a really
easy can't miss option to bring to the
raid no matter what is going to be
divinity
which is rough because i know that a lot
of people out there don't have divinity
because think of how many people out
there
raid bungie has shared the raid numbers
and it's like only like what like
five to ten percent of the community
like even like has completed raids or
something like that and then you have to
go do a special hidden
challenge in the game to get dfinity um
but that that'll be huge especially if
you're
not very confident and popping off with
like really big damage
um divinity is great you can just give
it to anyone on the team who's like i'm
not comfortable landing i don't know
sniper shots on a boss like run divinity
yeah you'll be fine uh another really
easy slam dunk which i'm definitely
going to bring to the raid no matter
what is a blinding grenade launcher
all you need is one
in a perfect world it will have auto
loading holster
uh if it doesn't you'll be okay but that
really is the ideal
situation blinding auto loading because
then no matter what even if the enemies
are really cracked fire off one quick
nade they're all blind
yeah control the situation much better i
also really like wither horde i don't
know how well that's going to do
i mean we don't know anything about the
new raid right we don't like nothing but
um but that should be
it's really always good for crowd
clearing stuff like that i i
got that email y'all get that email of
like your most used
exotics
i don't know if they combined the pve
and the pvp numbers or if they just did
one over the other apparently my number
one most used exotic
in 2021 was wither horde which is weird
because i never ever bring it into pvp
so i must have played a lot of pvp
um but yeah great weapon those would be
really safe
picks for me
nice
e
uh yeah i mean i know we've got weapon
crafting coming or excited about we know
absolutely nothing about the raid but
we're all kind of
hopeful about it and obviously hoping
the story lies true
um the big one for me is void
void 3.0 seems like for one something
that i can't wait for solar and arc 3.0
because once we get our hands on this
we're like all right i need those now
and one of them is going to be six
months away but for you with regards to
just you know you jump into the
legendary campaign you may not do it
solo but if you do
is void point three void 3.0
intriguing enough for you to just be
like okay i've got actually kind of
understand this quickly or are you going
to fall back to another subclass
oh man i i'm going to try and understand
it quickly
for the main purpose of
content creation
yes yeah
your views on how you play a game
uh change a lot
when you either have a youtube channel
or are a streamer especially if you make
the jump to full time but um
yeah i'm gonna try to really
get my hands in the dough on void 3.0 i
mean it would be stupid
for me for me
uh not to just because there's i feel
like there's a lot of opportunity and
potential
to do fun wild crap
uh yeah so so why the hell not i'll
probably be doing that stuff day one in
addition to power leveling yeah i was
gonna say are you pretty the new exotic
the devour boots just seem like they are
gonna be extremely powerful so you're
gonna have to duck off and find that
lost sector on the right day for boots
like first
thing actually one thing i was going to
do tonight i don't know if this is going
to work for witch queen but um you know
that trick where you have full n-grams
and then you do a lost sector and the
exotic engram
goes to your postmaster
and you hold it there and then you open
it up and whatever's on the master that
day boom you get that uh i don't know if
that's gonna work
but i'm going to try to hold things at
my
because then that yeah
like maybe day one i'll get whatever the
new exotic is right away and that would
be really cool
shout out real quick to a couple super
chats necromancer zone ten dollar super
chat cog and follow what are your
feelings on warlocks and witch queen any
suggestions for day one uh those two
would say yes take that class into which
way i'm just kidding
five bucks got cancelled tonight last
second so here you go welcome welcome
thank you glad you got to see it live
daniel
yeah
so
are we are we on youtube or twitch right
now we're on youtube youtube nice okay
cool
uh i did want to ask everybody did you
have outside of the exotics because
thunderlord was higher on mine than i
thought it would be too for some reason
which i was like i didn't know i had
like 9 000 kills with thunderlord but
apparently i do
i saw that on a couple on your emails
that you guys got was there any
surprises or were you just expecting
exactly kind of what you saw
for me i was surprised how much i
crutched on outbreak perfected
i was like damn i'm really crunched and
you gave me a lot of crap for dad rifles
so welcome to the party
[Music]
and then now it's even more exciting
because we know the primary buff is
coming to exotics so i'm actually trying
this weird spot where i can't wait to
take graviton and a lot of those
primaries to see what that extra 40 is
going to do to those red bars and then
yeah 50 or whatever yeah exactly and
then what we talked about with the
scavenger
synergy with getting heavy
i'm excited i'm excited for the first
time like will an exotic primary better
you know
might work out in pve where i don't have
to always crutch here come the galley
here come the sleeper like everything
you know we crutch on it for the dps but
it's just like that's the party that's
exciting to me but what about you trap
uh my
so something must have gotten wrong with
mine uh
the the two the second and third uh
highest one according to my stats were
vex mythoclast and uh thousand voices
both which make total sense because i
use those guns a lot this last year but
then my number one by a lot was uh
crimson
really which i have never used this year
and i checked in my vault
it is power 1150 and i have i have not
taken it out of the vault in several
years and uh did not use that weapon so
i have no idea what maybe maybe you
touched it hard in the beginning like i
did yeah that's the only thing i can
crazy
11.50 though that that's like years ago
like yeah remember that catalyst
wouldn't kick that crimson catalyst
everybody was was going i love that
catalyst it was crazy that range and the
reload i have the catalyst but i i swear
to god i've not you they said i said i
had something like thirty five thousand
kills with it jesus like i there's no
way i would remember that like so i i
think there's something wrong with their
data in that one the other two
definitely make sense
some seem a little trippy what about you
travis or sorry uh follow what about you
any any shocks in your email where
you're like yep i play warlock a lot
i mean the warlock was not a shock to me
it's 55 i got 55 percent warlock oh nice
uh oh wow that's less than i thought
yeah i try to i try to keep things even
uh 28 hunter 18 titan
uh i know there are other
content creators out there cough cough
watts i [ __ ] see you girl out there
with your like 100 percent hunter
variety in here
don't judge us
i mean
mix it up watts had to go warlock for a
charity goal i'm calling you out
i'm calling you out girl
um but yeah i was shocked that i was
like where are they pulling the numbers
from either they pull it differently
than i
i don't know either they pulled it a
weird way
or i spent way more time
trying to do solo dungeon challenges
than i thought number one was wither
horde
and number two was risk runner by a lot
like triple the the kill numbers of what
my third most used weapon was which was
crimson which like in crimson early 2021
i did a lot of pvp with crimson before i
changed my in-game
ads settings
crimson is a really
really easy gun to use i play m k and
controller
and when i play controller crimson slaps
hard but now that i've done my
settings change
like thorne
is just my favorite gun ever the thorn
just like it doesn't matter if i'm
playing mnk or controller
i
i just love thorne but yeah crimson made
sense but risk runner and wither horde
with like triple kill numbers
i was like wow i must have it took me a
long time to get the solo flawless
prophecy dungeon done
and those two guns i used a lot in that
activity yeah
nice
uh for me to no surprise mine leaned
very heavily titan without a shock
uh thunderlord was up there
which was still weird that's like the
oddball for me i had like
thunderlord up there uh risk runner was
up there which was a little surprising
but maybe i'm just chain lightning so
many guys that just added up quicker i
couldn't figure that one out either
um
but yeah like i mean it wasn't too
surprising i spend more time the open
world is always weird because that i
think encompasses
dungeons and a lot of things that i
guess it just falls into that bucket so
it's like oh open world seemed actually
way heavy and then it was a decent split
in the gambit's like two percent which
i'm not surprised at all because well
we've been waiting on some of what's
coming
and still we're not even sure if it's
going to be enough but um
yeah like with regards to this week it's
been absolutely
chaotic for most of us
and it started tuesday we got the launch
trailer everybody got up early in the
morning and talked about the launch
trailer so with what you guys saw there
and i want to ask you first fallout i
don't know if you're a big story lore or
you kind of get the update from bife
every so often
with regards to like seeing what we saw
in the trailer did it did it pump you up
even more are you like kind of lost
about the story you're like very excited
to see where they go cool um it's really
cool i love when i read into the story
i'm like oh that's tight you know what i
mean like reading the um all the deep
lore dives it's always very
interesting i feel like the game has
so much deeper lore than most people
know
uh my fiance knows i think a great deal
more lore about the game than me
like there are
certain questions that i'll have and
she'll be like yeah duh you didn't know
that like
um i'll be like oh zebu or wrath is like
hunting sabathune and anna's like yeah
she's been doing that for like a year
i'm like
i'm like oh rip my bad
yeah
there's just a lot there's just a lot to
take in with the lore so yeah life what
a brilliant business model man find a
game with really rich deep compelling
lore that no one understands that nobody
understands nor do people have time to
go out of their way to understand that's
right
and just record
videos with a charming british voice and
just
clean it up out there
yes
silk pipes out there
that interactive trailer really did a
lot
that's cool it for people who haven't
read anything like uh my girlfriend's
planning on playing this new uh
expansion but hasn't really kept up on
any of the other stuff and she saw that
interactive trailer and was like i kind
of want to read those lore books you
have on the bookshelf now like she got
into it so i thought that was cool yeah
it was really cool to actually see them
potentially either tease a really deep
history for the hive visually because i
know like i mean obviously biff has done
like the book of sorrows and we've heard
about fundament probably the only words
i've ever heard spoken fundament was
from biff's voice so now to actually see
it on screen and looks like you've got
you know the traveler leaving
potentially causing the syzygy and
you've got the three worms that are left
which i almost know the names of now i'm
not gonna claim them because that's
still a question mark but it's just like
they're going that deep into the lore
with her
to really see what's going on into which
queen i'm
they've been building so much story
momentum going into witch queen
that i think if they can deliver on this
thing it's gonna set a new bar for
storytelling and destiny if they can
because we had chosen to set it up then
we had splicer with mythrax and saint
and the perspective of saint and then we
had everything with marisol building
this thing up and obviously we'll talk
about the trip to the finish line that
we just had
but other than that i mean the story has
been really good and if they can go huge
on an expansion it has me really excited
the way they finish up these 10 years so
i'm pretty pumped especially for the
story big question
can they tie it into the raid can they
somehow get savathune and the pyramid
ship in her mind connected and that's my
big question i thought they already did
a solid job at the end of the trailer
even that last couple of five seconds
and she kind of like insinuates like you
know
she's kind of make some some snide
remarks like you sure you know what
you're getting into kind of thing and
first of all shout out to the actress i
forgot there was a devil
oh yo she's crushing it crushing it
every time
she makes me uncomfortable like even
we'll talk about it later yeah it's the
last even we'll talk about later what
happened we finished up this season but
as far as the trailer specifically i
loved it i thought the musical choice is
great
and then just the the oppression of
seeing
the hive using our abilities against us
you know what i mean i really just like
the whole scene that that set and of
course i'm always going to be a big fan
when i see them all multiple characters
in the room you know saying and you see
i finally see eris i'm like okay there
we go you don't say like we're getting
the it feels like the end game style
event that i've always wanted destiny to
do so we're here we're here what about
you chad like when you i wanted to say
one thing real quick when you said the
hives using the guardians it's like it's
cool that we're all going to get
suppression grenades but fall out i
wanted to get your thoughts about the uh
suppression grenades sure sure
for everyone in general like
yeah you're void 3.0 right it's just
really it's just really funny like yeah
i i think it was really hard if you
could go back in time and be like hey
did you ever picture a world where like
you know a hunter or warlock has a
suppression grenade he's like no
like no one would
think that
big deal
yeah they're kind of they're kind of
blurring the lines a little bit with uh
they're trying to lean and bungee keeps
talking about their goal of
leaning into like the build craft
fantasy a little bit they still want
like
titans to feel like titans like hunters
feel like hunters but they still want to
encourage kind of
unique build crafting so i think it's a
ballsy move keeping the other classes as
a suppression grenade but uh it's all
part of the the grand bungee design that
they've got going on so i'm i'm sure
it'll it'll be okay it's their 10-year
plan travis what about you on the
trailer any airplane any big moments any
hype or
my favorite trailer watching that uh run
and gunning titan oh very very proud to
be a titan that day actually as has all
the marketing really for this trailer
it's really uh highlighted titans as
badasses which i thought was great um
but yeah the the trailer i thought was
incredible i'm just really really
excited to see some lore actually in the
game it looks like which uh god i've
been asking for that forever uh so that
the fallouts of the world can actually
follow the story without having to get
in
um and i i think that'll be great but
really the highlight of the week story
wise was you know getting to see sabbath
in bully tassie on twitter i think
that's the funniest thing ever
i really think that's uh that that's
that's really the their their best idea
they've had what whether yeah title or
uh
in the past or or sabbath now that's
just been getting me hyped up like she's
here she's ready to mess with us so yeah
she burned quite a few people yesterday
the one was like i just got my warm
excise i don't need another one that was
also pretty damn good
very funny there were some epic ones
shout out to gaming addict in the in the
chat two bucks travis was wrong as
always uh great show by the way so you
messy
i didn't know what i was wrong about
this just something as always shout out
to cassie by the way he will be joining
us next week as long as the his uh his
child does not uh appear into the world
too soon so we should be
should be good to get the live review
from the forbes man so that should be
fun yeah good guy and if he if he can't
come next week i hope it's because his
child was born on release date and
completely ruined any ability of him to
cover
that would be
cassie
who plans a baby for witch queen
you don't make love to your wife unless
it's in between experiences
we can do it now otherwise we gotta wait
like three months i'm sorry that's just
how this works exactly yeah i respect it
i respect the hustle
so i wanted to ask you guys since i
think most of us had a chance to
experience it or at least watch a video
about it
the season of the loss finale
finally got here it took 26 weeks or so
to get here but we did finally see the
finale
did you all get to experience it as
intended or did anybody have any errors
there were a lot of issues with people
for some reason you can skip the
cutscene that is extremely important to
everyone in your fire team that's kind
of a mistake if you run down the bridge
that got built too fast
you gotta bat go back um yeah there's
multiple quests won't progress if the
cutscene gets it skipped did you guys
get to experience it first and then
what did you think of it
i got to go to cog first because there
was a big one in there for the warlock
so the osiris man sir this is me shout
out to um attic who played with me who
had the glitch i did glitch for me once
you know um so it didn't uh progress to
step two so i had to do it over but yeah
though i liked it i liked it it was um
as we got you know further on and you go
i like the defense little sequence
outside right they try to give the
illusion of like yo
see if harass forces are coming gotta
hold it down shout out to the um the the
was it not the techias but the ones who
work for for mara i forgot they always
get the dream in city with the masks
that they got the i forgot the name what
you call them officially but like
petra's um yeah yeah
whatever like yeah on the side of you
right here this one moment
he would he would know he wouldn't know
by foot no but shout to them you know
appearing like they were in the wall
with us i like the little touch you know
i say but yeah once we got there and
then uh yeah the reveal happened and i
will say again cyber dune has some cold
lines
tomorrow and i like that he was like
something to effect like not as you know
just as tenacious as your family like it
was like little jabs going back but i
was like okay and then obviously
you know i was in i was in fear for my
man's life i'm a big osiris fan so uh it
was looking real spooky for very
very a long time and i didn't think to
be honest i thought she was gonna lie
and just put his body bag on the floor
and be like i fulfilled my part of the
bargain
so shut up here
shout out to salad dude for having otter
you know what i'm saying it keep my man
alive i didn't think that was gonna
happen but um other than the bugs i did
like it but i want to give it to you
guys what did you guys think travis
yeah so i might not have finished it i
guess just uh what i did is i got i did
the mission and i saw the cut scene
didn't really have any bugs but the
mission didn't progress for me
and i saw online that people were having
trouble with it so i just deleted the
quest i was like well i saw the cut
scene so i think i finished everything
and then
is step two you go and you listen to uh
uh an audio log yeah there's like a
voicemail at the compass yeah so i got
to do that part it just didn't progress
mission for me so i think i saw it all
and just didn't complete the mission and
uh i think i'm good i don't know maybe
i'll play it again
today or tomorrow yeah i played it but
uh
yeah yeah i played it one extra time for
capture sake but yeah i will say just
like the look of the final tower
surrounded by the
projection of the worm when you saw that
the first time i was going that's pretty
cool
um i i what i did want to say though was
for me
i i was worried i was wondering the
reason they kept pushing this thing so
long was it going to be february 1st
with the real astral alignment was it
going to be the eight so we have about
two weeks like we have before it was the
final week
and nothing about this finale in my
opinion
had to wait this long everything with
regards to the witch queen has been
completely isolated
no but like 100 100 agree with them and
actually i thought it was underwhelming
because they made you wait so long and
we basically just got kind of a revised
version of astral alignment and then a
very very small cut scene that kind of
told us really nothing we didn't i mean
we got to see that osiris is alive and
that we she didn't get caught surprised
the whispering didn't get yeah
you know but uh i i think other than
that it it it didn't really
do too much to improve my hype to be
honest i i kind of agree with you they
could have just done this on the the
last week of the the rotation and uh
and left us wondering what was up with
sabbath unless there's some reason she
has to get the light like a week after
getting freed from the crystal i don't
really see the reason behind it
what about you good times you're just
like cool now let's go to which way
yeah i was like cool i uh i just
everybody kept especially paul good lord
never seen a man try to hype up so much
like okay the mission is definitely
coming this week it's like relax already
like
you're we're over height we're putting
it on a pedestal kid's gonna be sure
it's gonna be like just gonna be a
little cut scene that's it and then it
turned out to be just a little cut scene
and then that was it so it's like which
it was fine um
i i did get to watch the cutscene i got
lucky
the group that i i did it right at reset
apparently everyone wanted to watch the
plot
as badly as i did um
and i'm gonna get flagged for saying
this it's it's
really put yourself outside your body
right now and just admit just admit that
it's really funny
that bungie made such a silly i'm sure
they made it by accident right the fact
that you can skip the cutscene for
everybody in the group
it's funny should you be doing it no
don't do it it's a dick move don't do it
let people watch the cutscene don't be
that guy come on help a blueberry out
that being said it's funny
um but i do hope that everyone gets to
experience the completed mission and
watch the cutscene because i can only
imagine the frustration of trying to get
it done and people just being rude so
hope they get that fixed it's just i
can't help but laugh that it's like of
course
of course that would be a thing going
into which queen why wouldn't that be a
thing shout out to tp hayden by the way
shout out to two your favorite warlocks
cognito and fallout thanks to the great
show good to see you live very nice
thank you very much hello
max yeah i mean that was my biggest
thing it's like i enjoyed kind of the
spectacle of the projection of the worm
i like the little back and forth between
mara and
sabathune deborah wilson is absolutely
killing it in pretty much any time she
speaks
uh her laugh and then just the final
line thank you as just but that would
have been perfect to have on week nine
or whenever it would have been we were
like okay so we're going shadow drum
shadow drum got them all the witches
together we go ahead
we the witches are together and then the
next week you hit it right as we're
there and not so far later that we've
honestly forgotten what the hell
happened five months ago that's the only
thing about this and i've talked about
this i know
but to me especially this one because if
it would have been like her busting out
and then some interaction with the
traveler and the light and that would
have been kind of the giveaway i would
have understood it being this close
as it was literally bust out of the
crystal
deuces and that's it
there's no reason this needed to have
the waiting period i understand they're
doing it for the hype and all the
promotion i'm giving
i can't help not helping the marketing
team i know
i know
that's not his job
i'm talking from a player right now
thank you very much but the other piece
they could have done is at this point if
there's if they do like a chapter nine
of nine of season of the lost and then
do a prologue of the future stuff now in
game put something in there do a little
interaction when you log in and you see
something with like sabathune in the
trailer and you or something along those
lines would have been a better piece
that would still do the marketing
purpose but you're not waiting four
months to get your final chapter in the
mail that some reason they forgot the
rest of your book type thing so for me
it's
just the delay that bugged me most
especially once i saw it i was like nope
i could have seen that four months ago
and everything would have been the same
that's all
yeah that's fair
that's my only
only gripe not too much
that's not that bad of a grape just not
marketing your game and getting people
ahead
he gives me a hard time because i'm not
a fan the fact that they killed kade
spoiler alert in case you're like four
years behind he killed kade
yeah you literally can't play it and
play it in about three days
why didn't anybody tell me no but it's
the fact that they did that in the
marketing trailer that's what always
kind of bugged me i was like if i could
have experienced that live in game
that's more of those moments i
understand the marketing but this one
doesn't quite fall under that umbrella
anyway i hear that smug cognito sound
over there uh the big rework is gambit
we knew somehow they managed to wait for
gambit to be the big final 12 and we're
going you think that the thing that i
have two percent of my playtime in is
your your final hype swap you were
talking about marketing talk
this is how you nail marketing your
final twab hype is gambit
just the wet part of gambit they were
pumped they had stuff to talk about
i don't know why they're doing this yeah
the sequence is a little weird a lot i
was surprised
i joked like six weeks ago that they
were gonna save gambit for last when
they announced that was about it i was
not expecting to be right
yeah yeah it was interesting so we going
to get into this yeah so what i want to
read is first these bullet points
that they were very accurate about these
are their goals and i want you guys to
tell me how many of these goals they hit
when you're playing gambit uh you can
showcase both your skill at fighting in
destiny and the variety of focus on your
arsenal should be just as inherently fun
and rewarding as shooting aliens in the
face in gambit as anywhere else
i what is the bullet point there that
they want us to have a variety in the
arsenal or something yeah they believe
that gam
we believe that it is important that in
gambit these things are true
do you believe
you can showcase both your skill at
fighting and destiny and a variety in
your arsenal
not really no okay a good you have to
play to the game type yeah a good
invader should be able to turn the tide
in a match but a good invader should be
no more important than any other equally
skilled team member yeah they missed
they missed that mark for sure
then the invaders can like completely
ruin the match right yes yeah and then
yeah
yeah 40 seconds into it pretty much
players defending against invaders
should have ample tools to fight
invaders without worrying about using up
ammunition dealing with other tough
enemies
yeah it's a little rough on that one too
it should be rare that it matches out of
your hands as a player or an outcome is
pre-ordained early in the match
[Music]
yeah i almost never feel like
if i'm going in with a team i feel like
it's kind of under control if i'm going
into gambit alone i have no i have never
had any control ever in my life as a
solo gamer player
working together with your team to
overcome tough enemies the primeval a
high-value target or an invader should
feel as gratifying as a hard nightfall
you know
i don't think they'll ever
yeah it feels gratifying but in a
different way that you just stomped the
other team and they're crying in the
corner
anyway i want like a quick chuckle yeah
i wonder if they think nightfalls are
rewarding
so what different discussion he said do
you think
hard nightfalls are rewarding
depending on the difficulty level i
think they just met not from the rewards
standpoint from a gratification
standpoint of facing tough enemies like
you've conquered some tough challenge
you overcame that's what they tried
travis yo yo why you got that face
yeah we know it's that i've never beaten
a nightfall and been like wow i'm really
glad i did that it's a little bit like
eating a hot pocket
all right jim
thank you very much for that
um
no but like in reading that if that's
what their goal of gambit is
and i know i'm giving them a hell of a
hard time right now so if you guys are
listening believe me i know making a
game is not easy but if those are your
goals we have as you can hear been off
the mark for a while so they're actually
trying to do quite a bit to
address a lot of these points and
generally it feels this is them and this
is them admitting that they that they've
yeah this is the copa this is the
miracle but this is yo yeah the next
paragraph yeah
at least we have clear goals where like
in if in which queen they put out new
gambit and it just feels bad and we
could be like hey bungie this is your
your goal bullet point list i ain't
feeling that level of
satisfaction number three is currently
not happening right now thank you
yes uh so they have upcoming challenges
for the for
gambit they got the core activity ammo
primeval invasions and rewards obviously
to make it recording first thing
freelance gambit
how do you guys feel about that
i think that is uh like i get that
they don't want to be separating the
playlist more and more because like the
more they do that it just
gets kind of hard to find a match you
know what i'm down i hate going into
gambit alone
because i just know like first of all
why am i going into gamut alone i must
be doing it to get like
a pinnacle or something important
related to equestrian item because it's
like
there would be no other reason for me to
step into gambit and if i do and i go in
alone i'm always going to get slapped in
the mouth by a full stack of four who
for whatever reason like
gambit people they they hit on a
different level these gambit people man
god love it play play the game however
you want but like i'm so glad that you
have something that you enjoy playing
that you feel like you succeed at but
like holy [ __ ] dude some of these teams
are like they feel like they're training
for like the mlg
gambit grand finals
and i'm like damn man you don't have to
go so hard like there's no
if there was like a halo remember the
halo
ranked system you're going for you're
like you're you're level 50. i feel like
they're going for their level 50. if
they had that that would be really cool
you could then that would justify some
of the ass whippings that we've gotten
in gambit
but yeah i think the freelance game is a
good idea um what about you guys any
any reason you wouldn't want freelance
gambit in there very curious about
traffic once with this oh no thank god
dude this is essential they needed a
freelance gambit because i mean i i hate
playing gambit i will i will never do it
of my own volition unless
it forces me to do it uh but
if i'm gonna do it like the worst part
about it well no sorry the first worst
thing about it is that nobody who plays
the mode knows how to play uh unless
they're you know not the people you get
matched with anyway uh the people on the
other team always know uh
because they're on four stacks that's
true but uh that's the worst thing but
the second worst thing is that uh
there you run into full stacks and it
just it just destroys you uh so i think
they needed to do this that's like the
single easiest thing they could have
done and they could have done it way
earlier than now by the way they have
the technology uh we have the technology
they could have done this a long time
ago i'm glad they're doing it now it's
necessary and i i mean i basically only
play
gambit by myself because
why how in the world could i convince
another person to do that to themselves
and what i want to do
so yeah i'll be on the freelance
playlist quite a bit but here's the
problem the people who need to be on the
freelance playlist
they're not going to know how to find
that freelance button that's the ego
five percent besides you know
how like i was literally playing i was
streaming freelance iron banner not this
time like the last time it was in town
did that
i was just streaming and uh talking to
chat and i opened up the thing and i
queue in and like
at least like four people in chat were
like whoa whoa whoa what'd you just do
i was like what do you mean it's like
they didn't know that there was a
freelance
iron banner that's a good point yep
that happened to me yesterday fortunate
for you like on my smaller viewer scale
on twitch but
because this man over here is a monster
roast don't roast yourself like that man
yeah there's nothing else no um same
exact thing happened i was literally
like rooks probably sitting here in chat
and he was like wait a minute there's a
freelance i was like there's a freelance
for this there's also one for survival
so make sure he's like
seriously that one too and i'm going
what year are we in in destiny and this
stuff is not obvious to people it's
that's true and they i mean they kind of
hide them off bungie doesn't make it
obvious that's the thing first i was
laughing like oh look at this goofy
player he doesn't know that like
freelance is a thing and then the more i
thought about it i was like wait a
minute like this is on bungie like they
need to be telling people like the new
life players shouldn't have to like
discover through a twitch stream click
on it and you're on a fire team by
yourself it should suggest it should
give you a pop-up that goes hey you're
alone would you like to queue into
yeah you know solo player version like
why do you need a clip like it knows if
you're alone it knows if you're alone it
just pops up a picture and says have you
applied lube yet go here or here
right
and then when you click on the normal
matchman version he goes this is amazing
you're going to die but have fun
ridiculous ridiculous now i want to say
like this tells you how little i've
played gambit when the rotating seasonal
selection of curated encounters i didn't
know this was a thing
like when you go to pacifica you always
face hive or you always see the
shriekers like it's a set encounter in
certain places that's how little i've
played gambit and they're finally gonna
have the technology a year later to have
some rotation here now they're gonna
make like
a season have certain encounters and
things and they'll shake them up by
season but we've had the same exact
encounters for a year
could not have told you that was a thing
did any of you know this i wanted to ask
i actually did that
i don't pay attention to that kind of
stuff
i didn't
know they were set per location i did
not know that i also didn't i was
surprised to read that and i was like
you know what that makes sense i don't
remember
getting anything but knights on on the
map they were talking about it
that makes sense yeah shout out to the
shriekers
shout out to attic by the way guns for
every slot for the raid besides divinity
we might touch on that in the end if we
got time he wants that fallout plays now
though he like i did tell fallout that i
need to know what rave energy weapon
that he's gonna use because i mean we're
not gonna know go watch
at nine o'clock in the morning an hour
before the raid goes live or two that
says
this is what you should probably jump
into the day one raid with so wait for
it it's not a bad video idea and you're
gonna probably get it not a bad video
i was gonna say that i'm surprised i
think you've already done the 50 games
in gambit because i was going to say
since freelance is coming you should
i was like i've watched that people are
calling people are calling for uh
another one
50 games of new gambit i'm like
well hey it's for the content man so
that's true
you can trim shax's junk once again
i love that by the way that's like the
homework
the level of homework
i'm a fan what can i say
uh so respawn points are actually going
to be added to all fronts basically
where the enemies can spawn so you're
actually going to have respawn points in
all places i thought this was huge
because every time you're like all right
i have my six mile hike across the map
to get to my to my buddies over there
and they're also gonna have um basically
invader points over there they're gonna
also have heavy ammo which we'll get to
in a minute kind of spawning over there
as well so the enemy fronts and if you
die the respawn timer is going to be a
little better
they are actually changing up the feel
of the game it is potentially going to
feel different back in the action
quicker um
all in all generally good things and the
fact that if you do get you know all of
a sudden you turn around the corner and
there's six orange bars hitting you in
the face and one of them's a mini gun
when you die half of your moats are at
least going to fall on the ground
do you guys like this change do you
think this is going to like level the
playing field if you stub your toe too
much or what do you think is going to
happen here what do you think about it
it is helpful because
people that die to adds which tend to be
players that either don't know what
they're doing or are kind of
most likely going to be a drag on the
team won't hurt the team crazily but it
will actually give invaders an
opportunity to do a lot more work
because they can pick up the moats
dropped by the people that they kill now
which actually lets them end the match
even quicker if they're really good so
i'm interested to see
how that because because it does help
the players but it also has the
potential to help really good invaders
be even more effective at ending the
match quick so i'll be interested to see
how that changes things
fall out what you think um yeah i think
the changes overall
are probably for the best i think that
you know it's really funny way back in
the day when they first introduced
gambit i
flew out to
the uk to co-commentate
a gambit tournament with bife which is
like the first suit
for this yeah really funny to think
about now
but uh it was actually a lot of fun i
think
in a different universe
gambit could be
i know this could be really memed on
hard but like in the right circumstances
with a different
with a different set of goals gambit has
the potential to actually be fun
competitive but i don't think anyone
here now including me
wants bungie to really spend
a crazy amount of time or resources to
make that happen i just think it's kind
of like a fun
side core activity that people
want to go into without feeling
like they just got punched in the face
and have to throw up for like five
minutes so i'm fine with that i'm fine
with i them just making changes to make
gambit a more
palatable experience
to make it to make it suck less
uh have
good rewards and all that and all that
junk um i think they're on the right
track
i think it's the best thing we could be
doing with gambit right now nice
what about that sony sony money though
don't you know they're spending that on
movies it's not like we had a
pre-deposit
1.2 bill of that sony money it's going
right into gambit brother that's it
brother
that's the other game they're working on
it's just a gambit stand alone
bass
sony would be taking a big risk on that
one i can tell you uh shout out to scott
schultz by the way with the twenty
dollar super chat absolutely glad to get
this live great content thank you very
much for being here
fallout bringing in
all the love tonight um
i did want to actually ask you guys with
regards to
uh the next piece when it says all
shields have increasing resistance to
non-matching damage types so it's like a
half a match game does this bother you
guys already since half of the things
like later in the match i feel like you
faced nothing but bosses as it is
do you think you're actually going to
have to lean into like loadouts arbalist
is going to be with you all the time
what do you guys kind of see yeah
probably just our blessed i feel like
that that one sort of
they they said that they want to
kind of improve the type of weapons you
can use and i feel like that's the part
of their patches that they're trying to
address that but in my experience it has
the potential to do the exact opposite
which is make people fl make players
feel like they have to use a specific
set of weapons to match the fields and
then they're gonna have to divide and
conquer among their team to make sure
everybody's got you know they've got
coverage and i kind of feel like that
has the potential to go the opposite way
on them so i'm kind of interested about
that one but we'll see
yeah there's one of these i got to see
it when i play it you know it's it's
variation right now you know it sounds a
little weird but until until we play
we'll see we'll see how it affects your
loadouts and stuff just get your
herbalist catalyst that's all i'm going
to say probably many benefits coming up
definitely do that including the
legendary campaign that's going to be
big one uh the next piece is the
blockers draining all that stuff we've
got and honestly this one is kind of
some nice tweaks they said the phalanx
is going to be a little beefier the
knight is going to have a stasis attack
so potentially messing you up a little
bit if you get closer and then the one i
wanted to ask you guys about was the
moat drain just to see what you guys
take on this one is
they say the moat drained from multiple
blockers continues even if the opposing
team is in its prime evil phase says
this will help the team that is behind
get to the primeval a little quicker it
never felt great to send over four
blockers only to have the team ignore
them this also gives the team in the
lead a bit more incentive to kill the
blockers do you guys see that if there
are blockers and the prime evils out is
it just constantly healing them or what
do you think it's actually doing
no i just think it's um so let's say
like uh my team has prime evil up right
for whatever reason we're playing 3v1
gambit all three y'all versus me right
my prime evil is up
you're still sending blockers over now
even though my meter is like there's no
motes to drain from
you're still draining in the sense that
i think that your moat score is going up
so if i want to prevent you from getting
your prime evil quicker even though
you're not stealing moats because my
prime equals already up you're still
auto generating additional modes every
time i'm not dealing with multiple
blockers you're improving your moat
score it's kind of like a ketchup
mechanic yeah yeah
um i am
not i i don't like ketchup mechanics
like i i feel like
yeah i know it's a bold take uh
spicy there's no participation
og gambit felt like i love speed running
do you guys watch yeah like when people
do like mario 64 speedrunning that [ __ ]
is really impressive shout out to mark
medina
yeah dude that's really cool um og
gambit
felt like a scramble
and then i think when they started doing
all the
the revamps to gambit it started to feel
like
they were including a lot of ketchup
mechanics which again i just didn't like
like
it could be me putting way too much
thought into gambit but like to me it's
sort of like
if you were at a baseball game and like
by the seventh inning one team is up
like 5-0 it's like oh well
we'll give you a run for free it's like
wait no it's supposed to be like a
competition right
everybody hates the blue shell on mario
i know the mario kart ketchup mechanics
are
annoying but like tracking red shell
mario kart right there yeah it's a core
mechanic of mario kart but like
again like for what bungie's trying to
do which is make gambit suck less like
i get it like i get what they're trying
to do i don't really like ketchup
mechanics but but sure why not if it
makes people suffer less in gambit then
i'm i'm down for whatever they do
shout out real quick to gaming forte
with another 10 super chat shout out to
the coincidence joe that i just listened
to the 60-second twab then to my
surprise i see fallout here have a great
show i'm off to make this make sure i'm
not the weakest link on my raid team
that's right get ready get the load off
ready keep asking
questions to fall out he's ready
that's true
uh the next one is ammo economy and this
one actually seems like we're almost
going back to a little bit of d1 days
kind of but we will
kind of have to see how this one goes
basically when completing a front any of
the three places where they spawn
a small container of special and heavy
ammo spawns and you got 20 seconds once
it's open to get it if you kill a high
value target you're gonna get a heavy
brick for every player and then they
said limited special and heavy ammo
bricks to only spawn
from enemies if you have the finder mods
equipped
correct me by the way if i'm wrong
finder mods are also on your helm where
our orb generation's going to go
i'm really waiting to see how that are
you guys worried that that helm is just
really going to get over stacked or
overused yeah maybe yeah
yeah maybe
that was my master working concern like
over under take away a little bit of the
value of the mass work when we lost that
and then we talked about it with the
whole synergy with that armor 3.0 we
keep asking yeah
well that's i just kind of wanted a
quick take on that but yeah it seems
like you'll definitely be swimming in
heavy ammo so when you do get those
invades you are probably gonna have some
as long as you're nearby the fight so be
in the fight and you can respawn closer
all in all seemingly like a prisoner i
don't mind it i was going to say real
quickly only because there's some times
and gambit was just weird with the with
the heavy economy and you're just like
fam i didn't get no heavy the whole like
come on like you know
like it's a very helpless feeling
sometimes when you don't have any
especially during the primate primeval
phase so yeah i don't mind it
yeah big things for the primeval um
the envoys are now
it's basically gambit prime is what it
feels like there's going to be envoys
around the map they're going to have
different shields if they're up the
primeval is going to be shielded
and
they also said since they're kind of
mixing some of this stuff up and which
prime evils actually can spawn the
malfeasance is you'll be able to get
that anywhere else but the envoy's not
going to be affected by the
what is that stack i'm blanking on
the prime evil damage thing evil slayer
yeah
yeah so you're gonna be seeing uh and
then also the envoys respawn at 30 of
primeval damage done it really seems
they're almost forcing every gambit
you're gonna have kind of some damage
phases so do you guys think you're
actually gonna be able to nuke or is it
what's going to be the strategy divide
and conquer or just like move as a herd
and kill everything together
for most players it'll probably be moves
or heard
insane people like
glad chevy like type level people will
probably find a way
to
instanuk but i think for the average
player it'll be like let's rotate and
get those envoys you know
those crazy gambit players that fall out
was referencing earlier i feel like
they'll find a way to nuke no matter
what because they might play i've seen
them play and they they can
they can put out damage if only they
would apply themselves to activities
cared about they could they could really
clean up and yeah reversible or really
anything just do something else with
your lives guys i'm just i was like
bingey on twitter right now i was crying
inside but that's fine
oh
i follow that guy yeah he's a beast if
you've ever actually watched him play
yeah yeah he's a good guy he's a good
guy yep
uh big thing is for invasions level
advantage doesn't exist anymore
invasions are at 40 and 80. uh you can't
save them up so use it or lose it which
thank god for that
um
and you also no longer can see how many
moats players are carrying and then i
think one of the coolest things i was
always wondering how they could balance
out the invade the see-through walls
forever
and i think they actually found a
perfect example is when you're ads
you can no longer see through walls but
when you're not ads you can see the name
plates so if you're looking down a scope
somebody could move while you're looking
but you come back out and see where they
are and change do you guys feel the
invaders getting handicapped too much do
you guys think this is fair and also
invader kills are a
27 healed of the primeval every time it
had been anywhere from 5 to 35 which is
all over the place apparently crazy
yep do you guys think this is a good
change for the invader a fair change too
much too little
i think it's fair i think i don't think
it's ever really
ideal if you can tell exactly where
somebody's head is before they walk
around the corner and have a chance
that's that's not that's not happy
that's slaughter
yeah i don't know how i feel about the i
guess i'm trying to understand the
mentality behind taking away
the moat number
you know what i mean because i don't get
that one specific player no because i'm
using the guy that's hiding in color in
the corner when i got 15 and i hear the
alarm going
so i'll keep like i mean maybe it's
going to be better for me but i'm just
curious from the invader standpoint i
guess they just felt just look for the
deer in the headlights who hasn't just
while you're looking at it yeah look for
who's out there and don't target that
person i guess for competitive purposes
to
i don't know i'm just curious it's an
interesting it gives i guess more of a
dice roll to who you kill so it's not
always right three people have no emotes
if i can do everything in my power to
use my thundercraft super to kill this
one guy it'll set him back and i think
now it's just more of a dice roll you
could kill three of them and the one to
15 still live so i guess that's the
point again as
fallout said
kind of more of a
leveling the playing field not so much a
ketchup but not punishing
not partisan they're not punishing
yeah i think that's what they're going
for
fall out what you get
i think it's fine i uh anything they can
do to make the invader a little bit less
strong a little bit less annoying is
good
so yeah don't give them the total free
well i always thought the wall hack was
like way too much that's right
yeah that's free super super free but
yeah so i think it's fine we'll see how
it does yeah no doubt
yeah basically gambit is gonna turn into
trials if you go to the drifter he's
gonna have the same focusing he's gonna
have your weapons and armor that you can
go for you're gonna be able to focus
engrams that you get from him and
theoretically we're going to have the
same thing for future vendors
and they talk about this as being the
entire year most of all your standard
pursuit nodes up at the top
all of their vendors are potentially
going to get a rework similar to this
one end-of-match drops
are going to be kind of the new weapons
so those are still going to be for one
season long so if you want that new
bottom that hype bottom dollar that has
60 000 perc options you still got to
play gambit you will not be able to
focus quite into that one as much
um but they've got
basically they've got crowd pleaser
bottom dollar trinary system borrowed
time and then servant leader those are
gonna be your focuses along with the
armor and then gambit is where they
actually talk about so we're all gonna
have to play it a little bit the weapon
crafting you don't sound enthused
guys
you gotta do our homework guys
the host called out over here not
enthusiastic
it's just the way
yeah it's likely we all should
definitely check out this new
reinvigorated gambit so you can get your
weapon crafting
i don't
know no it's like the skin the ornament
whatever the weapon crafting
cosmetic is the first one comes from
gambits we're all gonna have to play a
little bit and be like are these cool
and worth my time or
you know i feel like it almost pictures
me like a call of duty like a little
thing hanging by the scope or if you
kind of ads that it's hanging there if
they do stuff like that could be kind of
cool get a little like trials sun
sitting on the side of your gun or
something like that but
get those little gabby specific perks
down right don't we get those little
gambit focused you've been in there you
get plus yeah of your attractions
travis
the hockey the hawkeye gambit auto rifle
the one that does damage to vehicles
which we don't have that many of the
turrets
but also apparently no but also like the
gambit i think the gambit origin perk is
going to be like
invader tracking i think that's what i
saw one place yeah
so that actually you're gonna have a
gamut perk that makes it so you don't
have to play gambit yo
that would
it's like you need to do
you need to do eight gambit bounties or
go into the throwaway and shoot shoot
enemies with this yeah
i put that on every weapon in weapon
crafting
[Laughter]
anywho uh the one i actually did want to
ask you guys about
gambit labs they are going to mess with
things a little bit
so that's pretty much most of the
changes basically gambit seems like it
is going to feel very different more
heavy ammo in a reliable way invasions
in kind of randomness you're able to
respawn much closer to your team prime
evil is going to have shields if you
ever played gambit prime you got an idea
gambit's gonna feel a little different
so jump in definitely let all of your
awesome content creators know if you
hate it or love it so that's what the
comment section is for just play nice
that's all i gotta ask
uh but gambit labs actually sounds
interesting i wanted to get you guys
takes so the invasion swap
so this lab's variation plays around
with who gets the benefit of triggered
invasions so during the modes phase
instead of opening your own invasion
portal at 4880 you instead open your
opponent's invasion in portal when you
dunk uh we expect this to completely dis
disrupt the accepted meta uh and when to
deposit and invade so i was curious if
you guys like this idea or not um travis
is kind of like shaking his head are you
like
actually when i read this i thought
actually that kind of strikes me as how
it should be
it it doesn't seem to me like the person
who's ahead should get to invade and
like stomp on the person that's behind
it should be the person that's ahead
should make themselves vulnerable nah
that's the way it should be
if you're ahead you should you should be
rewarded by being able to stop yourself
if you're better and you are ahead and
they open the portal and have a chance
to kill you and you're better you should
be able to just kill them and it's not
an issue but if you're just ahead
because you're good at pve and you're
bad at the pvp part here we go they
should be able to come in
for it with some pvp skill that's
awesome here we go
again people in my twitch chat seemed to
think it was a funny idea so i'm like
i'm down with it i think i think it will
be a funny idea but to me it's just
bungee
disguising cleverly another ketchup
mechanic
oh your your team's in first because
you're really good at dunking modes and
slaying out well we'll give the other
team a shot to come be a thorn in here
what it will do is it'll make it so that
the team just keeps all the moats until
everyone's ready to depress it all at
once you go
all together every time because i
wouldn't i would want to wait to all
right nobody deposit like wait until we
all have to
go in and throw it throw four nights all
over their bank
yeah i would like edge because this is
it like it's 40 and 80 for the
yeah i would have everybody on the team
like edge at 39 so hopefully there's a
guy on the other team like by the portal
like oh yeah like waiting to go in but
we're like no we ain't opening that up
yet so you do 39.
and then everybody on the team dunks 15
at the same time and it's like bam [ __ ]
now you get invaded but we got all the
remotes i was thinking yeah i was like i
was thinking what travis said that you
could have four nights at the same time
and yeah if you did 39
somehow like magically get that number
so there's no portal and then everybody
has 60 so then you dunk and you're at 99
one person just runs off kills a random
thrall and you're good to go on the
prime evil you could really control it i
just thought it was
kind of fun and unique uh cog you is
this going to
be a catch-up mechanic or you think
you're going to have a little fun with
this
i'm in the middle because there is a
part of me that gets the satisfaction of
melting like there is something about me
that loves going in there and just like
yep it's over and i'll be honest like
i'm a fan of the quick pinnacle so i
don't have the vehicle
against gambit that everybody else has
i'm like this is the quickest three
matches going now the next stuff that
we're gonna get into when we talk about
them damn oppressive bounties that they
want you to stay in there pass them
three matches that i want to get out of
that's what i want to discuss but this i
mean look it is what it is we'll try it
but i understand what travis is saying
though with the with the going back and
forth they have to do something so that
you know
people
yeah you know what i'm saying like you
know he wants to feel like he didn't get
pump stomped and i get it and if it
overall helps the mode and
you have a player count
to go with those words right there if it
gives you the tone and helps out those
guys and if you could just pander a
little more yeah look really i like
melting them out yeah i ain't gonna lie
like
probably over you did it brother and
then it's over yes you're like i could
just have a faster loading screen you'd
be done in no time
uh the other one is going to be moat
thief fundamentally the original concept
was like the guardian invader was kind
of a terror
uh but basically normal moat drain
from having two blockers is disabled
instead every second the invader is
invading one moat drains directly from
your bank to the invaders bank and i
gotta ask does anybody think this isn't
gonna be anything but send the invisible
hunter to the other side
when i read that i was like well it
sounds like it's just going to promote
invader camping but like
i don't know i mean
maybe if there's people out there who
want to invade but they don't feel like
they have the capability of
popping off because they're not cracked
to pvp i don't know let them if they
want to be a sneaky heidi person i just
feel like it's going to promote slow
gameplay
i don't really view it as a um as a way
to change invader behavior i view it as
a way to uh change defending hate uh
behavior because right now the go-to
move is everybody just hides and waits
for 15 seconds or whatever for the guy
to leave and now you can't really do
that like if the guy invades you you
have to come out and challenge him and
so as a as a uh as a invading maine
myself on gambit when i play uh i want
to get out there and just like walk in
the center and be like who will
challenge you know like i want that
gladiator what's going on send your
champion
[Laughter]
i want to be able to come out and then
be like all right we have to kill him
like we can't just like wait for this
guy to just uh pick off all of our modes
so i think that
could potentially be a really good
change and then you just combine these
two and all hell is loose
yeah feeling it
uh the final big piece they touch on is
ritual awards uh basically it just talks
about at the start of which queen the
ritual playlist uh will be updated to
grant specific gear so the world loot
pool it's not going to be vanguard plus
30 other things seems like it's actually
going to be focused into crucibles
crucible vanguard vanguard gambit gambit
so if you're going for bottom dollar
hopefully now it's like one of six as
opposed to one of 36. so it will help it
seems a little bit in-gram focusing um
will only be available on saint and
drifter but that's going to be a thing
for the future the world engrams will
continue to drop at major ranks of
rituals so you get the engrams will be a
little more variety but the end of match
type drops will be a little more focused
um so it does really seem like they're
trying to lean into each of these
playlists having kind of defined set of
weapons and it all i guess falls on them
to keep them fresh
um but overall changes to eververse nope
no changes
she didn't get nerfed
why would they even
reduce this
i feel like that is the truth
yeah that section like if you have no
changes why put it in there why talk
about it they're having fun with it they
know we gonna say so they have a phone
they could have put a section about
crucible and been like yeah we're not
working on that mode either we
completely forgot it
so hey they actually said two crucible
maps are returning so i need a thumbs up
and thumbs down from my crucible players
eternity and vostok are we happy are we
sad
i'll take it
i'll take the maps
that is the most flaccid response from
three guys i've seen
i got it
he's used to through flaccid responses i
just don't like yeah that was paul yeah
that was pause worthy
but i just don't like those maps
especially eternity i hate it it gives
me the d2 vanilla scout meta it's such a
reminder
i hate that yeah it took me to a dark
place fall out
and what are we what are they going to
bring that map back for
not trials i hope right now
oh just wait
yeah bro because i think that was like
it was like the mighty meta the graviton
and vigilance wing and everyone was
laying camping and i'm just oh i hate
that yeah middle hallway
memories yeah that middle kill box
yeah that's pretty awkward i don't even
understand why it's there it's like for
for i guess
solo queuers okay so i'm sure playlist
so vostok on the iron lords mountain how
we fe is that one any better than
eternity because not a lot of love
sounded for that one i would rather play
on vostok yes as weird as that is it's
not a map that a lot of people enjoy but
yeah whatever i haven't played on it in
a while could be a fun little throwback
why not
yeah i don't mind that one as much and
plus from the lord's standpoint i'm like
all right i don't know it's okay gotta
be a little biased
but yeah there you go there you go
honestly they should just put all the
maps back in like it's been so boring
lately with the same damn maps all the
time i just think uh
i mean hopefully we'll get new maps
because
the returning maps just really isn't
enough at this point yeah i caught i got
cassie's recap on the 12 and the one
thing he wanted was how do we still not
get gambit maps i know we now granted
that's like but that's kind of a thing
we get a game but reworking no gambit
maps but we're also like dying for
crucible maps but there's two gambit
maps just sitting there
they should they should add those back
but honestly like i don't care about
gambit maps until they until they fix
the crucible maps like obviously i'm a
crucible main and i'm very upset with
what's happened in crucible the past
couple years but uh that's just how i
feel
okay i gotta ask
is anybody not hyped for that void armor
the hunter eyebrow armor
yeah it does look pretty cool yo the
hunter's shining somebody that's the
eververse one right uh yes that's that
first universe no she's out here come on
yeah she's she's gonna be you know i
mean i i did 1200 new options
the two uh armor sets they showed in
that 12 the first one i was like ah
that's okay and the second one i was
like oh that's really dope and then i
looked and i was like oh yeah i paid in
pretty easy
can we have a petition one on the
vanguard ritual
armor
looks
like
bro like i know bungie i love y'all i
love you like but that's like
low-key
basic [ __ ] armor i'm pretty sure
look at come on i can't get jiggy with
that like i look that's regarding the
chocolate
[Music]
yeah that's your your standard
you know you got it from the bargain bin
or the thrift store and then they just
kind of hobbled something together and
then spray painted it so it matched the
outfit but that's basically what i feel
like the pursuit armor is always just
like instant trash i don't even know i
feel bad for the artists as you said
because you know they go through and
it's like it actually looks kind of
sleek it almost all looks like jumpsuits
and athletic wear and you got the little
you know jacket go it all looks kind of
clean
but there's not a lot going on and then
we're going to get thorn armor in the
dungeon and i'm going
why is it even there i do i do agree
with you that it does seem like a weird
thing it's like i know you have to drop
some armor but i'm almost at the point
of like we get so much more armor and
other places that were much would rather
have
i don't even know why sometimes that
stuff's there that may be harsh but it's
i gotta i gotta yeah ritual great game
recruitment van gogh on
gotta step it up boys catch the bell
uh the season pass is actually getting a
change speaking of armor uh they're
gonna bring back the high stat armor
which is good
so i'm actually excited to see that
everything else they're just kind of
adjusting some things kind of as the
high stat armor is coming back they're
going to have less of the things that
drop the armor and all those things so
it's going to be a little bit of an
adjustment to season pass mostly the
highest that armor is coming back uh but
i do think we have to all take a second
and we need to have a moment of silence
for the thrall way
yeah
yeah rip rip thrall away yup good round
it's a good run we appreciate you
good morning
yeah i was going to say i think if you
got to go shoot some enemies for a
catalyst it sounds like it'll work but
nobody's going to be season past level 9
000 has anybody seen this
i've seen pictures of these people who
are level 1 fifteen hundred now
um
the longest season ever and people are
just like i guess i'll leave my computer
running 24 7 365 to see how high my
season pass rank can get but
i don't get it uh boss stomps are
apparently going to be slightly adjusted
too
yes got a cool new emblem shout out to
all the streamers
any of these people who stream at least
the two on the top but over here it's
the two corners uh the new emblem for
the gifted subs on twitch
so if you're going to try and break a
sub record see if you can get fallout to
give you his lemon bar recipe
i would never get now
i gotta taste these lemon bars because i
love lemon bars so i need to taste these
things because yeah it's like i can't i
can't believe nobody has uh
hit the lemon bar tier on my patreon
page
it's not that much you know it's just a
small down payment on a house or
something
it's fine yeah i can't believe nobody's
signed up for it yeah at some day i
think somebody's just gonna blow you
away first off and be like hey anno rent
it's covered i just gotta give out the
recipe and she's like worth it
it's totally worth we're going to we're
going to vegas tomorrow though i'm
taking a day or two off absolutely you
know that you know that ridge wallet
that's going in the next video
oh
yeah it actually is a pretty cool
looking void emblem though i gotta be
honest that looks pretty good uh and it
looks like they adjusted the times so
servers are gonna go down at 6 45 p.m so
15 minutes sooner
and yeah we are almost wrapping up
um and then
looks like you can actually preload two
hours sooner so february 21st 7 p.m
you'll be out of the game pre-load your
console wherever you're playing
yes sir
that's pretty much everything so as we
kind of wrap everything up i wanted to
ask um
just each of you guys
going into this thing
the final piece is there like first
thing you're gonna do when you log in or
first thing you're hoping to see or
just kind of the final piece before
because this is the last show before we
get to dive in and pretty much know life
it and live on advanced gg for the next
few weeks so
plug i see plug
it's like i got my new sour apple today
it's actually pretty good there you go
salute
what you doing fall out
i i don't know man i'm gonna take this
weekend to try and just chill a little
bit plan a little content
plan a little future content but for the
most part try to chill relax because uh
it's gonna be mad fun and i'm looking
forward to it a lot but i want to make
sure i'm
well rested treat my body right you know
all that stuff so
yeah
yeah i mean i'm good go trap
yeah i was gonna say i'm i'm uh kind of
done with all of my destiny prep so yeah
i'm just gonna chill for a bit and maybe
play a little bit of crucible which by
the way one of my stats was eighty-five
percent of my time was spent in crucible
wow at least you live into it so that's
good
slow
it's pretty high uh but yeah i'm i'm
probably not gonna see a whole lot of
crucible at the beginning because i have
to focus on the review and there's
frankly not a whole lot of content in
crucible that needs reviewing that i
haven't already played 100 times so
um yeah i'll i'll say goodbye to my
beloved before i hop into the pve and
focus on that for the next uh two to
three weeks on how much content they
have um but yeah just taking it easy man
because the next 10 days after launch
are gonna be insane for me
for me it's just been about builds and
like i'm scheming on how new things
would be buffed so i haven't touched
void in a while as a warlock so just
kind of like
really getting into the mindset okay now
i'm gonna have these fragments and
what's going to change so i'm just
thinking of bills i'll bust out nezerak
i bust out a couple of like voice
specific exotics and trying to play
around so that's good i'm actually voice
3.0 that's literally what i'm actually
the most hyped about very nice i really
like
i i know titans don't like stasis but
for warlocks
we like our stasis we like uh you know
say behemoth we like our turrets we like
all that stuff going on so to have that
customization in void is very exciting
so i'm ready for that
the glaive just to see how it feels like
you know is the shield blocking gonna be
good is the projectile aspect gonna feel
good really it still looks like a little
one
i can't get a feel on that melee
look look little wonk but i want to know
is it truly going to be an effective
weapon and yeah just get this story
popping see what's going on with the
witch queen e what's the first thing you
gonna be doing i'm gonna try and solo
the legendary campaign literally to
record it as i go because for one if you
don't before you get to the soft cap
play the legendary campaign please it is
the best way to level up because you go
whatever we start at 13 50 to 15 20 when
you get done with all of them so you're
just going to skip the soft cap
and then make a huge jump into the
powerful gear so that's and i want to do
it on the first one i may like take
people in with the second one but
there's a lot of people are going to
jump in and be like can i do it how can
i do it and the whole goal is to tell
people yes you can
it's possible
and then but i also want to experience
what i hope is a very special campaign
with a challenge because what a
challenge
yeah and that's the thing
i was like whether i'm playing dark
souls or i'm kicking my ass on sifu
whatever it is it is kind of that so
that's basically it for me
and
that's pretty much what we got so i know
we're kind of on a tight time i got to
get fallout off to his yeah we gotta get
the rest of his world so as we wrap this
thing up quick outros um but first
follow let everybody know where if they
don't know you please go look up fallout
please you'll find the man thank you i
appreciate it behind the voice but yeah
let them know where they can find you if
you got anything you can find me on
youtube.com
twitch.tv slash fallout plays and on
twitter at fallout place and thank you
very much for having me guys oh
absolutely and it's the homie i'm sorry
i'm glad we was able to do it and like i
said every every uh destiny con of gcx
you're like one of the first people i
always bump into on the field i'm like
oh what's something it's a yearly
tradition it's a tradition
so we can't wait we got him here a huge
fan and by far one of first of the
crucible scientists let's give you y'all
your roses
you know what i'm saying and then at
that time at the end of the day one of
the funniest low-key content creators
like literally i'll watch something and
we'll just bust out laughs and shout out
to your man's kid cause you're the only
one that's making that like ads
hilarious like you get your elaine on
how to make doing it funny so yeah
salute to you man you know
travis um
reviewing this wonderful game right i'm
reviewing the witch queen so you can
look for my review in progress i'm gonna
get it live the friday after the game
comes out before the weekend and then uh
i'll do my final review probably the day
after the raid so i'm gonna beat it and
finish my review and do the video over
the weekend probably
so yeah it's gonna be a crazy week you
can go to ign.com and see a ton of stuff
i've created this week uh crossfire x
multiplayer and single player don't play
those please
don't play those but you should watch my
reviews because they're yes
and uh yeah i said crossfire x uh is
plays like a game you a shooter you
would play to dave and busters
yo not the david busters
yeah so yeah you guys can uh you guys
can find me there and you can follow me
on twitter if you care about that on
thai guy travis
and for me it's ibontes twitch twitter
youtube you guys know it i'll be playing
like all these rest of these amazing
people playing and making content so
i'll be streaming uh living on caffeine
but i'm gonna try and meal prep this
weekend so
eat healthy food walk around get a
little bit of sleep in there
get some good amount of water and use
all i can say be healthy if you're gonna
know life this thing there's an option
there so as we wrap this thing up chat
you guys have all been amazing thank you
sir fallout i appreciate you taking a
little extra time tonight but thank you
so much
thanks for having me guys absolutely for
this episode of the last word it has
been
the last word
the last words